it may not be certainly you could argue
that doing sleep you're not burning as
many calories but I think that probably
just enough sleep to be comfortable and
not tired is is no specific number that
I never overweight obesity is almost
certainly hereditary about seventy
percent of your weight is genetically
determined and that's identified from
twin studies and things like that it's
actually a closer correlation than
height your weight is going to be more
similar to your parents wait for the
most part then your height is going to
be similar to your fansite you got to
work really hard to make sure that your
lifestyle and and habits really do
everything you can to negate that and
that means being really careful with
your intake being really careful with
what you eat how much you eat when you
eat it and you exercise and exercising
regularly helps maintain your metabolism
up because one of the things I was
talking about before regular exercise
helps keep your metabolic rate Bob it
may not cause weight loss by burning off
calories but as you diet as most people
who are overweight diet your metabolism
slows you take in less calories your
body uses less calories in response and
that's why people stop losing weight is
their dieting even though they keep
their calorie count down when you
exercise it counteracts that metabolism
rate decreasing by exercise you can keep
your metabolism higher and therefore
those less calories will end up in more
weight loss ultimately but if you don't
eat less exercise by itself for the most
part isn't done applause wait
you